what's up reject nation I am G train
I am j-bird and today with us we're
doing a special video with Warren from
the channel the cosmic wonder how you
doing Warren am i w train is that what's
happening yes sir yeah anything that you
can modify with the W it's I'll leave
that to you you know yeah okay good man
you look great
W block so right now Warren what's just
give away you're doing on your channel
uh my giveaway that never ends I'm
giving away an Xbox one or a ps4 the
winner gets to choose I started I think
when I hit five hundred thousand
subscribers and it ends when I hit five
fifty took a while to get there which is
why it's been going on so long but we're
almost there so if you'd like a chance
to enter subscribe and leave a comment
on the video as long as you're there
before they release ps5 and that's what
everyone's saying they're like dude
you're gonna have to do a new giveaway
soon like I am and I let's not rush
something under the rug though okay
Warren might have it he's only at the
time filming its 542 thousand
subscribers and now some people might go
but Gregg John you guys got seven
hundred seven thousand subscribers hurts
you guys defeating Warren in every
category and I'll tell you guys the
answer is Butte County is freakin
stellar it is like it's impressive
Vica and so I'm he absolutely deserves
to weigh surpass us in subscriber count
and this was his idea for for the video
and I was like absolutely dude we did
one last week where we talked about
Wolverine fan casting for his chance you
guys can go over to there but today we
are gonna do fan tastic I just gotta be
a pun here
fan fan casting casting I was gonna say
that yes fan fan
but can we make fantastic have also fan
for stick in it yeah and forced Bank and
forced cast it's in the video today so
what we did was this time around and
last time we had war into his own poll
on his community patron we did ours as
well but we had different picks for the
most part to keep being simplified to
keep things condensed what we decided to
do this time here's what it is I pretty
much stole Warren's text we said
reteaming with the cosmic wonder this
week for our Channel last week we asked
you who do you like to see Casas Bovary
now we're asking who would you like to
see cast members are fantastic for who
should play the Fantastic Four on the
MCU comment with an actor for each role
we got an actor a sign for each
character the thing Human Torch
Invisible Woman mr. fantastic and other
and we will talk an order from least
voted we have a tie on our end no two
most voted so Warren you kick us off
first who is your least voted okay Emily
Blunt as the Invisible Woman she's
released voted she's my least voted
which I found like extremely surprising
because most people want John Krasinski
and Emily Blunt since they're married to
play mr. fantastic and The Invisible
Woman since they're married and
everyone's like it's perfect and I was
like huh interesting part of me wonders
if people are packaging Krasinski and
Emily Blunt is probably yeah it's hard
right how do you yeah how do you include
four different teams in each one I guess
so maybe there's a little bit maybe it's
a skewed a little bit there I personally
think that she's a great pick and I
would love to see her and John together
in a movie especially a movie where it's
like they're together in the movie right
so I think it would be a great pick and
I actually think she looks the part and
I think she was you the character
justice a lot
well let's backtrack here
there's no way she can be better than
Jessica Alba yeah Jessica Alba like that
yeah no I agree without your defining
when she's in there raw in the city that
moment for a lot of kids was that's why
they yeah for that specific moment right
there no she really was and like
everything don't like her hair color and
just the behavior with her and read like
everything was perfect so I agree with
you there like to me
I like that Fantastic Four right to me
that's the Fantastic Four to me now the
ones that followed whatever but I
actually liked that movie a hundred
percent genuine yeah guys subscribe to
the cosmic wonders so many awesome
things okay I don't understand and you
know what while we're at it I like the
prequels to Star Wars to sue me I turned
I'm sorry your export and then see if
you still want to subscribe I I've
always liked him maybe because I was a
kid when they came out and I'm like I
really want to be a podracer now I don't
know I don't think they're as bad as
everyone says they are but it's just me
well to be a hundred percent fair and
honest I do find a lot of fun in the
first Fantastic Four and I actually
enjoy Attack of the Clones
many jokes I want to make I mean Phantom
Menace I can't meet you there but attack
of the clothes I think Emily Blunt we
have we're tied where we have to at nine
percent no pepper not including other on
here but we got to at nine percent Emily
Blunt is one of them and I would agree
with John people are probably lumping
her into that category yeah spoiler most
people won't watch Lee in any way John
Krasinski's the number one pick
I was I was actually kind of surprised
with that because I thought there might
be like a little bit of a split here of
Emily Blunt has to be a visible woman
and John Krasinski has to be mr.
fantastic so maybe there is a thing in
the voting here of people are just
assuming that if you're getting Junkers
in ski you're probably getting Emily
Blunt sure because for me I think that
out of anyone that we put down here the
one who will bring the most value in
terms of a top caliber shining
performance I feel like would be Emily
Blunt as the Invisible Woman but if
we're gonna talk about her would you but
you got to just kind of go out of order
here yeah break the rule of what I
established John Krasinski an Emily
Blunt like yes they they did star in a
quiet place part one together but what
we haven't gotten truly is a movie that
showcases their hilarity and like I mean
it's more than just them being funny but
Brett I don't know if you've ever seen
interviews with those two yeah it's very
apparent the chemistry that they have
and you're like yeah these two should be
together forever and I hope they're the
celebrity couple that never yeah they're
not only incredibly charming together
they're also really funny and and their
romance just seems to just it seems to
shine on camera when they're sitting
next to one another and like they're
both exceptional a comedy I think that
Ford needs a little bit of they need
some of that comedy stuff in there
especially for gonna be in the MCU now
right I think that John Krasinski and
Emily Blunt are the two picks that I'm
sure most people will be like that is
perfect you would be correct reading the
comments on this post there were two
things made very clear and one of those
two things was most everyone likes John
Krasinski and Emily Blunt yeah it's like
a Martin Freeman Bilbo situation I feel
like they kind of are the perfect
casting and I think it's one of those
rare moments where yeah if they pulled
the trigger on that I think everyone
would be pretty psyched well yeah I mean
I can bring the they're both scientists
with a loving history with each other in
real life yeah well the original comic I
believe they were start off engaged and
eventually got married and had
kid who I believe is like a crazy-ass
mutant oh oh yeah he's anime girl level
mutant yeah I have theories about this
that I'm doing future videos on but ya
know to break any of them guys go
subscribe to the cosmic order got a
scoop for us so well so the mutants are
coming to the embassy right and
literally their son is an omega-level
mutant like one of the strongest mutants
alive literally in one point time in the
comics everyone in thing is destroyed
and the only things that are left are
him and Galactus and it's just like
that's how strong he is
he's like insanely strong so Kevin vibes
already said that Fantastic Four coming
he's already said the mutants are coming
we just have to imagine that at one
point in time
he's coming as well yeah well they
should make John Krasinski and Emily
wants real kid star people are not
really factoring in the whole scientist
part breath mr. fantastic because when I
think about that John Krasinski in
science role is not something I really
associate with the guy but then again
what he did post office post office post
haha that should be when the office gets
picked up again on I heard his work as
Jack Ryan is pretty cool Michael Bay
movie he was in he actually did a really
cool job at that film and of course in
the quiet place is awesome so yeah I
know doing the action hero type role he
can definitely pull off I'm sure the
scientist stuff is something he can pull
off too he seems like a smart fella he's
proven he can get the Marvel bought for
films that are not Marvel related but
what if mr. fantastic need to be a
little bit more what we want mr.
fantastic to be the buff build that John
Krasinski has or do we want to have a
bit more of like a Grant Gustin bill
that's really skinny yeah it's all
stretchy guy right yeah
and that's the thing is
fires motional puns well I don't know
right because I think it's the same
thing it works both ways I think people
group Emily Blunt in with John Krasinski
but I think they kind of group him in
with her as well right because I think
it's the couple that everybody really
likes and they're 9 a mic like you were
talking about how they are with each
other in interviews because we've seen
them both do the action right Emily
Blunt one of my favorite movies this
edge of tomorrow with Tom Cruise Oh such
a good movie such a good movie and she's
done other things as well and then John
Krasinski you just named you know a
bunch of stuff he's done as well so we
know that they can do it but I think
people really love them together people
are kind of looking past like well he
should be you know he's always been kind
of skinny and lengthy right he's never
been like a super muscular guy I think
people can look past that to get I
should I like what the fans want right
but but you're not wrong like typically
he is in the comics and what we've seen
on screen so far a pretty lengthy person
yeah yeah not buff for anything now
would we want him to direct it because
right yeah and he has mentioned he would
love to direct an MC of film and of
course everybody's asked him hey have
you talked to Marvel about mr. fantastic
and I firmly believe that they have and
because what are they gonna say yeah
totally I've talked to them about it
rightly they're not gonna ever say that
until something is officially signed
right so you know Emily Blunt it was
revealed that while she was filming
Jungle Cruise that she talked tomorrow's
video who Disney owns of course that
they talked to her about a role and it's
like okay well we don't know what the
roller we role was but what do we think
you realized
I don't think you guys read these is
about a kid - when Billy Dee Williams
was Harvey Dent and then they replaced
Harvey Dent
with Tommy Lee Joe mark both we're
talking about the lowest vote about the
people in the middle now yeah well I
actually think that the people in the
middle are the ones actually we should
be talking about the most because I
think it's just like okay Emily Blunt
John Krasinski that so we want what the
other ones are kind of undecided right
so what are your who do you who do you
have who's your like second pick I just
want to point out that Emily Blunt was
9% as well so there was a three-way tie
there but then Zac Efron Human Torch 10%
okay he's our nine but if you combine
others he's nine we go in the lead Zac
Efron is the Human Torch honestly I
could see him doing it
I really can't and I think he's kind of
like Robert Pattinson has moved past the
whole Twilight right I think so I think
we're like Batman I think there was an
initial thought of Twilight guy but then
everyone also took a second to go oh
wait a minute he's done like a lot of
great [ __ ] Zac Efron has proven himself
as a wonderful like thing with the Human
Torch I think Chris Evans truly helped
define it the one thing that we're all
on board with is like out of that film
even if you don't like it Chris Evans
so good perfect yeah love that
rebellious charming attitude but also
you know hilarious and Zac Efron is that
guy they like people like me hate like
super athletics right I know right but
incredibly funny I think that he
actually would fit the mold of the Human
Torch pretty well like when I submitted
a pic and then I thought about like you
know he the movies I haven't seen a Ted
Bundy movie but comedies I've seen him
in I've never seen a high school musical
film but I liked his work he is so damn
fun
in those neighbors movies neighbors yeah
Baywatch oh my god he's even funnier
babe oh right yeah movie but he's really
funny and Baywatch yeah and I think he
absolutely fit that role what do you
think about him doing it I agree and it
I thought the same thing it's just like
Robert Pattinson it's like a lot of
people couldn't get over the Twilight
thing but then they took a step back and
look at all these awesome movies that
he's made so far right and he's not like
a super skinny guy anymore and I think
he's gonna kill it as Batman and I think
it could be the exact same thing for Zac
Efron he's moved past the High School
Musical and I've never seen a name so I
can't say anything about them but all
the movies the neighbors all that stuff
like that they're hilarious and like you
said Chris Evan kind of defined the
character on-screen as kind of like the
snarky charming like you said right but
he's like really really sarcastic a lot
too and just really quick witted
and and I think Zac Efron could nail
that I think that would be a perfect
role for him I I really do the only
thing that could beat it is if they just
simply brought back Christmas in the
comments there are a few basically
opinions along those lines in a couple
different places right yeah it's funny
because Chris Evans had a lot of roles
like like a king to the Human Torch
there's a personality-wise back then I
mean he kind of brought back the douchey
persona with knives out oh yeah that's
still a performance with like gravitas
right yeah but I remember like I think
the first movie I saw was not another
team boy friends right yeah
Humphrey what are your thoughts on the
Efron I always have Zac Efron in this
role for all the reasons you guys have
listed he's one of those choices where I
wouldn't be overly hyped about it but I
also wouldn't be disappointed in any way
I'd be like he's a solid pick there is
however one name that came up in our
comment thread a ton of times that I
actually think could be pretty fun and
that was de coeur Montgomery like yeah
hands down he was pitched the most for a
potential Johnny storm that's not
Zac Efron and I thought that was
actually pretty pretty decent choice
what I've never what has he done that
can really stranger things right Power
Rangers you know I'm not like I think
he's I think he does a wonderful ability
right in stranger things right yeah he
does I think it's a great job in terms
of things and I think for the most part
he was a fine Red Ranger I don't he's
definitely got qualities that really
remind me of the Human Torch be I feel
like it's really essential for him to
provide comedic relief like a leaf it
would be one of those roles where he
would have something to prove yeah it
wouldn't be was like sure bets but it is
one of those Gamble's that I could see
panning out
sure certain and we also got a decent
amount of Cara cutting back to last week
her engine name call-outs for him as
well and there's a Sam Claflin the other
name who he was in that he was in one of
those hunt he was in a couple Hunger
Games Movies as Brett the tall skinny
kind of friendly guy right by question
about our picks though is I would and
you've brought this up in your videos
recently born subscribe to the cosmic
wonder 500 50k you brought this
frequently as a late of how they're
going towards a lot more diversity and I
and and all things considered with
before we move on to the thing all
things considered with the fan for stick
film that josh trank did but they did go
out of their way to put Michael B Jordan
in the role of the Human Torch they did
yeah in case you guys don't know he is
not a white person I need to make that
shot for people who don't don't know
that yeah we pull up this information
the basketball player is not a white
person Michael Jordan's
and I don't own the original comics they
are Caucasian and honestly as much as I
am someone who champions diversity
I mean freaking look at me 23andme but I
don't I don't necessarily have a problem
if I'm not gonna be like why the [ __ ]
they only cast white dudes for this do
you think at all that they might want to
go try to find someone who is not
perhaps their look is not put it bluntly
a white person
we better get so many more puns in here
by this I do think they will I don't
know if it could be for the thing right
because did you know it's a rock enough
that's where the most diverse range of
suggestions came right exactly right so
I I don't know now I do I definitely
know that Marvel and Disney are
definitely striving for more diversity
Kevin Feige Asst blatantly said that
many many times I am a fan of sticking
true to the comics however but if
something works I don't mind at all like
Nick Fury's Whiteland comics but Sam
Jackson's awesome hey we already got
David Hasselhoff okay so I think if it's
done correctly is all I really care
about if you cast the perfect person for
the role I don't care who it is as long
as it's a perfect fit for the role
pretty much it right really comes I
think what we often do in our fan
casting is people usually go for the
look right and I think that's why
especially for like Wolverine even
though when we do over in that was like
everyone's top pick right
we were both all three of us like well
there's there's personality and acting
that we're considering mainly but mostly
we'll do what fan casting is they do go
after the look and I but I think there's
plenty of actors
and this is gonna make me look great
none who come to mind right now who
could definitely at least bring the
qualities and the personality traits of
any of these people right I think what
these fan casting choices it's like we
always factor in do they look the part
akin to the comics as well but yeah I
just thought it was something important
to bring up because that's always a fun
topic right well one thing that was
interesting and looking at the feedback
- is that even started to come up in
people's fan casting for Ben Grimm slash
the thing because a lot of people were
picking really big meaty actors and then
I saw other responses coming in of like
well Ben Grimm doesn't have that build
it's just the thing that has that read
so you know like Ben Grimm doesn't need
to be the rock in regular Ben Grimm form
anyway
well let's whoa john-john segue thank
you is that a segue guys we did it
and with twelve percent off the segue
wait wait what wardens the guest on
Warren Channel what's segue to you
what's where percentage percentage or
the rock or for the thing I mean sure
same thing right the rock at 13 percent
and just because that I wore my rock
shirt this is a brand with an arm right
now I I kind of have to be guilty on
this one as well
I think the rock would be really good
because of his build right because I
don't actually think you'd have to put
too much rock on them like you'd have to
to make him look like the thing but you
just like paint it on just paint him
right yeah exactly boy look practically
the same Ben but at the same time so
that that's a perfect segue again you
have to think like they're not going to
do the Fantastic Four the same way that
Fox did them like they won't they're
gonna try to stay as far away as they
can from that because there's besides
the first one that I like so much a lot
of fans don't really like the other
fantastic four movies right I think
they're really are going to try to
differentiate between the two of them
right
like hey this is an MCU Marvel film now
right Disney this isn't Fox anymore so
you have to wonder like how are they
gonna make him look right how are they
gonna give them the powers that are
gonna make him kind of different because
we truthfully don't know but 13% I do
have the rock and actually in the
comments have a lot of people that are
like no I don't want the rock I can't
really see him doing this same thing
with us now was the second most
commented thing because even though
technically he is second place in the
voting sure he's always he's undoubtedly
the number one most talked about of no
the comments are all saying this is this
is a perfect poll because you have John
Krasinski and Emily Blunt on
d-definitely yes all right yeah rock
definitely no side and then a whole
bunch of no man's land gray area where
the other two characters I mean I think
I think the thing though make a drinking
game and all get liver failure these
puns are rock find yourself caught in a
rock in a hard place there's a couple of
fastening points brought up about this
that's like yeah one part is Ben Grimes
does not need to be a buff guy because
bang Grimes isn't and that's the whole
point of this deformity but far enough
deformities insulting to the [ __ ] the
rocks are signing petitions right now on
Twitter takedown in chemical space
action the flip side I would have if I
wanted to play a little bit of devil's
app was really devil's advocate it's
just the fact Ben Grimes is primarily
not been grinds early the thing because
that's the big part of his journey is
why am i this thing can traverse it and
his turn
to accepting it then then a different
conversation kind of opens up here the
the try not to say the other thing the
the other thing the other thing take a
shot
the other point I can bring up is is I
got so word he's not been he's not been
time okay the other point that I could
that I feel I could bring up is now Mark
Ruffalo plays The Hulk and that is a CGI
mocap performance right yeah I think a
lot of people really did appreciate when
fantastic for the first two live action
movies from Fox of how they put Michael
Chiklis in a in a real suit right and he
had to spend hours putting that thing on
yeah the way they say that it makes it
sound like they had a suit and they had
hours to put it on I'm just like people
appreciated that oh yeah oh yeah
regardless of whether or not you even
thought the effects of that were good
they were certainly better than the CGI
in the fan for stick movie right right
oh yeah
I feel like probably at the end of the
day the MCU to maintain consistency like
how they've done with Hulk how they've
done with Thanos that they would
probably just CGI mocap the performance
I could see that for sure I imagine they
still would even though I personally
don't want them to you know post Thanos
world and in a world where they have
Korg yeah right yeah well court was
actually I was thinking about that today
probably not too far often what they
would do for him you know yeah sure
that's very true probably not that far
off
just you know yeah just make him yell oh
really I said just bulk him up a little
bit more but I mean he's a big bulky
rock character that's essentially the
thing just get taken
honestly there you go cast IKEA and I'm
sure you could direct it at the same
definitely bring the humor aspect for
sure
I think Tiger could probably bring a
pretty amazing fantastic four room have
the right the requisite amount of fun
for whatever else they need to put into
yeah well Sam I guess like if we're if
they are doing mocap I guess it doesn't
really matter the build of the the actor
but if you're not gonna do mocap I think
you should be you'll be safer off with a
guy who has a build or do you do two
different actors I was like in the old
hope show yeah right for you doesn't
have to technically be the same actor
you could have somebody come in and play
just like a normal-looking Ben and then
all of a sudden it's John Cena as the
thing right what they should get is Alex
wolf from hereditary in Jumanji to play
[Laughter]
Kevin Hart could be the Human Torch yeah
got it we cracked it perfect we figured
it out there you go Marvel you're
welcome we're done so excited for Jack
black to finally play Doctor Doom you're
naming a movie I would pay yeah
surprising I thought this video would be
exceptionally longer than the Wolverine
one but oh we can get there oh yeah
strap in
hi I have some interesting comments on
here that I would like to talk about
that please that's what I wanted
interesting comment that I liked
surprisingly loved I don't think
everybody else would love it and I
actually don't know if it would work I
just know it would be hilarious
got James Franco is Victor Von Doom and
Seth Seth Rogen is the thing I've heard
a few set broken either name calls or
rumors okay I think I think James Franco
had totally botched the Doctor Doom No
yeah don't like James Franco
only cares if it's like an - likeable -
like I love James Franco I loved James
Franco in like the arthouse or Indian
the film's words there's two James
Franco's out there there's the James
Franco who's a passionate method actor
right and then there's the James Franco
who doesn't give a [ __ ] and I just and I
feel like in the bigger films he kind of
just coast by on charm and does it
really give it his all he's got a lot of
charming spider-man 3 but I think Victor
Von D I would not watch it but honestly
Seth Rogen is I I could really see that
for the thing I really could like I
always see him in the interview and it's
kind of like in that movie he just
doesn't care like they hate us because
they ain't us so I'm just like is that
what I would see on screen I would just
see them two of them from the interview
in the Fantastic Four right but then you
would have to make dave franco be mr.
phantom alison brie has to be she hold
this movie this movie has to have comedy
but i don't think it should be write a
comedy right exactly I think that's
where the Fanta I think that's where the
original Fox films especially the first
one was like pretty debatable for people
was like this is like Tim's story made
that and I think Tim's story makes some
really funny ass comedies and I really
thought his he did the shaft movie the
most recent one oh yeah it was I also
thought that was a history but I think
that's where like you need to be if they
only went comedy I'm not sure about that
but pigs are their thing on our end one
of the biggest surprises which was
actually one of my personal picks that
got commented the most was Terry Crews I
like that Stone Cold Steve Austin got a
few name checks and one of them like
that Andy Samberg has been and then
stone cold as things so I just I liked
Andrews that's I loved it that's a good
one mm-hmm
I love Terry Crews as a person but I
like him for that role that's I'm
Terry Crews once outside of a hot dog
restaurant oh there you go very nice
fella
hot dog that's super awesome yeah well
you know the one that I saw and I
actually I've done a video on this a
long time ago and I think this would
literally be perfect because Fantastic
Four coming which means the Silver
Surfer has come in and I personally
think Keanu Reeves would be perfect for
that role
ah to man his demeanor and the way he
speaks in the way the Silver Surfer is
in the comics and even how he was in the
rise of the Silver Surfer Keanu Reeves
would crush it I think you would just be
absolutely perfect for that role but
what they want to hide that sexy face I
wouldn't want them to but body silver
surfers body and I think I just think
that his attitude in the way he carries
himself fits it so well and I've heard
talk before that they're actually
thinking about just doing a Silver
Surfer film like on its own origin and
how everything and then because Galactus
is supposed to be the next big bad and
so maybe an origin film could be how
they first introduced Galactus like at
the end of it it's like well you save
your home planet and become the Silver
Surfer so that would be a movie to where
he would probably be himself most of the
time and then at the end become the
Silver Surfer then he can hand the role
off to some guy this is the best
conversation about Fantastic Four
anyone's ever gonna get it's the last
conversation you don't even need to see
the movie when it comes out just skip to
Galactus right away and we're done here
we go we should have done it's got
enough fourth person on this video oh
because we could have a fantastic
forecast
fantastic forecast I like it there you
go yeah but one word forecast one word
[Laughter]
guys Warren I want to thank you so much
for being here
Warren is someone who supports equal
rights especially Michael Ealy is gonna
play every faith is Warren is cool with
that you want everyone to know that and
and you know the thing is Jewish so
that's gonna be important part of the
movie too accepting of everyone so with
that in mind if you want some great
exclusive the one of these usually the
first person I see who to have a news
report out awesome Marvel news d c--
news you see you sometime to do Star
Wars right lately it's been a lot of
Marvel do you get a Image Comics news so
I actually started a separate channel
just for comics news it's called
superhero since I was joking
Wow superhero central I will subscribe
thank you very new it's very new but
over there these new comics news on it
and then once he reaches 2,000
subscribers he's given away fifty
blu-ray no movie on them but just the
blu-ray discs just the blu-ray so much
on so yeah go check out the cause it was
seriously it so it's a wonderful channel
and and in the time for our channel when
we're not getting that many huge
trailers we have found that covering the
cosmic wonders and all I've been
watching you guys for I think you know
two and a half years now I've like I
said before I was even doing YouTube I
was subscribed to you so this was a
complete honor for me thank you guys so
much for coming on my channel let me
come on yours is absolute blast I love
it so they made ways when did you start
your channel because we wondered like
first video I believe was in February of
2018 and then I didn't post another
video for like two months and then I
posted a video again then I didn't post
for like another two months and then I
got going so you got to 540 thousand
subscribers faster than we did
I had Avengers infinity war and Avengers
in game though and you know con two of
the biggest movies of all time so I I
contribute it to that though if I didn't
have those you'd be blowing me away
prometheus
I'm all for collaborations but when I
see a threat it's different conversation
there war now there's been plenty of
people who started after us who are way
sir I really do think that you you're
you're wonderful at your job your your
video honestly there's been some
information channels that I generally
it's like yeah it's active what they
provide information and some cool edits
and stuff I love how the edits are
actually simplistic yet your and then
your personality to back them up on the
information actually is really easy to
absorb it really easy to pay attention
to a lot of times use information stuff
I'm like there's a lot of information
being thrown we're over that with a [ __ ]
ton of visuals going on I'm actually a
hard time keeping up with everything but
I think you really know how to you know
how to provide a wonderful presentation
thank you everything you're doing it's
not it's not like I'm just reading some
report it actually is something that I
find very engaging so and I've watched
plenty of your videos now that we are
not reacting I don't just like oh oh
we're gonna write to it Oscar right now
I've covered I've watched by I actually
did a film this I watched your venom 2
trailer update video yeah so thank you
for doing what you do and I think you
provide a great service to the community
offend
why did I go so subscribe to Warren make
sure to get him to 550 K subscribers
real rejects if you made it to this
point of the video I have a question to
you guys who put down in the comments
your favorite ensemble your dream
ensemble for Fantastic Four how about
that fan cast your favorite side
character that's not gonna be speculated
about and who should Mel Gibson playing
the MCU subscriber the real rejects
click that notification bell but an all
honestly the main thing I care that you
do is subscribe to the cosmic Wonder
thank you guys so much for being here
keep a look out for some other video
we'll be doing some other time soon
see you guys
you